hi my name is Ryan Harris and in 2018 I
directed produced and co-wrote my first
feature film called Zoe Zoe is a
low-budget - no budget feature about a
young boy who over the course of his
summer escapes from his abusive
stepfather and goes to stay in this kind
of janky motel it's at this motel that
he meets this young girl named Zoe who's
travelling through with her brother
no one's always sort of formed this bond
and over the course of their time
together
Noah discovers a secret about her that
changes the course of their summer
entirely as always start a principal
photography in 2018 and it took about
nine months to shoot the entire film due
to the fact that we had to shoot only on
weekends because most of the crew and
most of our people were working nine to
five jobs including myself we also had
to fly in our main actor from another
state each time when we were shooting so
it kind of gave us we would shoot for
the weekend
and then that week I would sit there and
work and figure out what we were going
to shoot the next following weekend
during this process my team and I
learned so much about everything that we
did wrong and everything that we did
right and I wanted to share with you
three ways to understanding your crew on
a low budget to no budget film number
one is your crew wants to know on Zoe we
had about 10 to 15 people on set a day
and sometimes we had less than that
sometimes it was 4 to 5 sometimes it was
just my DP and I going out with our
camera and our talent and shooting due
to people's availability because we were
only shooting on weekends we had about 4
first day season 4 second day sees that
were on sort of a rotation so some
people were there on day one through
three other people showed up on day 20
other people were there midway through
the shoot so I really wanted to make it
a point that whoever was there on that
day understood what we were trying to
achieve that day not just technically
but emotionally so really know that your
crew wants to know and there's no such
thing as oversharing or giving too much
information to your crew because
ultimately they're there to make it
better the second one is your crew is
just as creative as anybody else on set
with Zoe in particular we really wanted
to make sure that because we were
bringing in so many different people and
we didn't have
you know a very conventional way of
shooting a film we wanted to make sure
that the people we brought in weren't
just technically masterful at their
specific craft but that they were just
fans of movies and they just loved
filmmaking in general and loved
storytelling so we really wanted to make
it a point that everybody that onset had
something that they wanted to say a
comment about how a shot was or we used
to gather people around like the
monitors from the boom obstacle
Department to grab to grips we wanted to
bring people in to just look at it
because they're gonna see things that
you're never gonna notice
number three is listen to your crew
really listen to them the thing that I
noticed on Zoey that I learned pretty
quickly was that it's kind of amazing
how your crew that has surrounded you
there's sort of like a fly on the wall
they see everything that that happens
they see everything that goes on and
they see things that you don't even
notice or doats right over your head so
it's really important that if you
provide a platform for them to safely
come and talk to you that you really
listen to what they have to say because
they're gonna point out little things
little nuances things that you might not
notice or they might come up with ideas
that you realize would have worked so
much better so really take your time to
listen to your crew when they come to
you and they talk about things because
it's really really important and it's
crucial because at the end of the day
filmmaking is a collaborative experience
so that's it on three ways of
understanding your crew on a low budget
to no budget film and if you have time
check out Zoe on Amazon Prime in the
summer thanks
you